this was the all hussein hospital in
southern iraq
now much of it burnt to the ground
these wards were set up for coronavirus
patients
they only opened three months ago to
help cope with the pandemic
the charred remains of victims are
carried out in bodybags
but families continue to search the
debris for any trace
of their loved ones the front door was
burning
and the back door was closed so people
were not able to get out
we managed to take some people out but
they suffer from critical conditions
and the rest of them burnt and died this
was a scene as the fire tore through the
hospital
fire crews tackling the flames
is a catastrophe
[Music]
it's a tragedy that's left me speechless
it's as though iraq has to suffer
anguish and calamities
turned into anger with protesters taking
to the streets and setting
fire to police vehicles iraq's prime
minister held an emergency meeting on
tuesday and ordered an investigation
but mourners blame the government for
mismanagement
and neglect this is the second time a
big fire has caused death and
destruction in a hospital in iraq in
recent months
claiming the lives of coronavirus
patients in april
more than 80 people died when an oxygen
tank exploded and sparked a blaze at
this hospital in baghdad
health officials say that could have
been the cause of this fire
too but that doesn't help relieve the
pain for those family and friends
suffering here today jillian wolf al
jazeera